you just did two more avatar sequels
what was it like stepping back into that
role ten years later it's amazing I've
been one of the luckiest actors in town
because I always get to reprise
characters that I've been coordinated
for you know at first hand
Neytiri by far is the most challenging
character that I've made and I have to
say that you know I'm okay being biased
she's my favorite I've gotten to be able
to live in her skin according to every
phase in her life so you know when you
come back to see her and and jakesully
they're not the young lovebirds it's not
a Romeo and Juliet story no they're
having to beat a lot more adversities
and it's going to be tough for us to
sort of sit back and watch what happens
in Avatar but I really think that Jim
will not fail to deliver how much is the
technology change though like are we
gonna just be blown away at this time
around the technology has changed for
battery I mean it has to read knowing
Jim he's always a step ahead so even
though technology changed since 2006
Jim's challenges but have heightened so
now the technology has to still catch up
to what Jim wants to do and Jim is a
doer kind of filmmaker and individual so
as I get fits if it doesn't exist I'll
I'll invent it I'll build it yeah so we
still had the same challenges and I feel
like that's that's what I missed so much
it was such a familiar space to inhabit
again and he is he's my favorite
director to work with and one of my
favorite storytellers we'll have to wait
until 2020 for avatar to but you can see
Zoey as Adelina fortnight in missing
link in theaters April 12th I know the
secret ways to the mountain is it hot in
here the old names crack open the window
doe oh that's better
she has a true sense of justice she's an
immigrant she buried her husband and now
she finds herself like questioning what
do I do Who am I where do I go so she's
in dire need of an adventure she embarks
on this adventure with them discovers
herself but discovers that being
selfless is part of self-discovery as
well being there for others
[Music]
[Applause]